à peine âgée de 3 ans unesco pèse déjà
près de deux tonnes arrivé le 25 janvier
c'est l'une de ses premières sorties
avec ses compagnons il découvre sa
nouvelle maison et ses voisins sont
arrivés depuis le safari de peaugres en
ardèche est un symbole fort pour le parc
qui se remet doucement de la mort de
vince il y a un an
unesco est à thoiry pour grandir dans
quelques années ils pourraient aider à
préserver son espèce la mère d'une
escaut et gestantes et va mettre bas au
mois de mars
et donc il fallait que ce jeune mâle
d'un kit quitte son groupe d'origine
donc il va rester là quelques années si
le coordinateur du programme de
l'élevage des rhinocéros en europe a
besoin de lui en reproduction dans un
autre parc
effectivement il pourrait repartir dans
quelques années pour s'accoupler avec
une certaine semaine mais pas de
naissance de rhinau prévu à thoiry
unesco partage son box avec bruno un
mâle de cinq ans et grassi la doyenne de
37 ans les visiteurs peuvent déjà le
rencontrer et découvrir les autres
nouveautés du parc
l'offre d'activités aérienne initiée
avec la tyrolienne du côté des lions a
été complété par un parcours dans les
arbres
on va évoluer dans des filets jusqu'à 9
mètres de hauteur avec une vue sur les
animaux de la plaine africaine
il ya eu dix semaines de montage dans
les arbres pour pouvoir accrocher ses
filets donc c'est vraiment une aventure
bondissante
on peut y aller à partir de 3 ans
accompagnés d'un adulte bien sûr le parc
de thoiry fête cette année ses 50 ans
pour l'occasion une nouvelle zone
d'immersion est en création
un trek australiens avec une volière
d'oiseaux exotiques et un parcours au
milieu des wallabys sera prêt pour le
printemps